okay because we're [ __ ] back and last
thing we need to do is enter the
twilight to poker which is where the
[ __ ] is that up to left okay okay let's
do this give me a little bit of walk in
you know I hate exercise I know you hate
exercise but we got to do it okay like
we kind of we're gonna play through this
I shut [ __ ] around eight leagues [ __ ]
okay I like a [ __ ] sheep to that like
all I would stand mode then was come
with knowingly run out of it
okay shut we had two fridays [ __ ]
okay I guess not and I think I one of
this last mission of this hold it like
thing is though wasn't like it wasn't
like oblivion where it was actually like
thieves quest like this would like to
play tracking people like we didn't do
any robbing
okay is that looks like it's that ok
let's do this pitches hey betch I don't
recognize but I sense that you're one of
us who I the last of the night in jail
sentence we will be trained by what I
was perhaps if I have been more vigilant
then was afraid I haven't heard her ask
alice the key and was afraid that i owe
you a great deal night game that's what
my only regret is that you had to run
kha liya I fear she stood follow the
same fate nothing would bring me more
from the moment i right the sepulchre
isn't merely a hint wenger the stove yes
I love [ __ ] target severely limiting
our heart I'm afraid so I mean that
whatever damage has been called can only
be correctly by following the pilgrims
path to the head entire tooth Betsy
great what's up [ __ ]
set it is a seat is this item with now
I'll show right on the very like that
test you like that this here [ __ ]
[ __ ]
[ __ ] now get these are [ __ ]
nuggets yes sabes ghostly heart what the
[ __ ] was that I honestly do not know
what the [ __ ] that was
we have five and back
well josh has a staff of light yeah I a
sad life
save here ok there's a speck
thanks for the set [ __ ]
the [ __ ] i go did I turn off that
mission kind of list all in the togas
path but i guess not back buck in my sub
thing now there's a mystery here a bit
but i have to like move for something
hmm what goes here what goes here like a
[ __ ] door
what's your ponytail
hmm
let's go see [ __ ] let's see [ __ ]
there's a checks of it out here that I
miss something
definitely the way to go
just [ __ ] am I missing
glad I shoot that thing you say if I why
they gave me the [ __ ] arrow
oh here we go
at bets and no
[ __ ] a [ __ ]
autosave
and
what the [ __ ]
cut the auto saved Jesus
what da [ __ ]
go ahead shoot these things okay let me
jump down here real quick how do you
read this
that he does not see a way out Oh what
the [ __ ]
what do we have here shouldn't be
looking at me in a number of years since
I said oh [ __ ] [ __ ] sexy once again the
key has been stolen and a champion
returns it to the seventh now that the
Evan air has been restored you stand
before me awaiting your accolades of
heaven who has a kiss on your cheek what
you fail to realize is your actions were
expected and the resin epsilon to the
booty don't mystifies homie for
displeasure after all you've immediately
performed your duties to the letter but
we both know it has little to do with
honor courage and loyalty car it's about
the reward the prize you know you'll
have one trinkets your desire for power
Taggart again well I did you to drink
deeply from the other mere mortal for
this is where the agents of nocturnal is
for the oath has been struck the guy has
been helped and your face Oh
in the episode thanks
I'm glad you are able to bring the key
back safely over here no penalty of
course we do can you write caca louder
oh and i gotta think of her a good
scolding mother to assure you she been
discreet the circle that the crescent
moon represents this is knocked up if
you ever be warmed that once you've
chosen you can't be select for at least
a day now your life is a nightingale
begins the guild I only hope that this
isn't an ending to things why perhaps
the greatest there are pockets brimming
with coin we may be nice and out within
our hearts were still sees okay okay
good what we do
thank you